Avoiding spoilers for a major event film like
Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker
can be a little difficult.
For those involved with the production of
Star Wars toys, going into the theater cold
can be next to impossible, but that doesn't
mean they don't try.
The good folks at CinemaBlend recently spoke
to a couple individuals in the business of
Star Wars merchandising, and they were quick
to confirm that ducking those spoilers can
be a real hassle.
Designing toys is a very lengthy process.
The long lead times mean that designers will
be introduced to new characters long before
the general public, sometimes years before.
This can often mean that it's necessary for
plot points to be given away in order for
a toy's manufacturer to understand why it
must be designed in a certain way.
However, according to Lucasfilm Senior VP
for Licensing Paul Southern, that doesn't
mean that toy makers are forced to hear spoilers.
At a recent event revealing a portion of Rise
of Skywalker's toy line, Southern indicated
that there's a surprising amount of leeway
given to those who are extra-determined to
avoid spoilers.
He told CinemaBlend:
"You need to have a basic understanding of
the architecture [of each toy], but there
are elements that are 'No, I don't really
want to know about that.'
There are actually people who are working
on the film products that want to know nothing
and they actually will not go to meetings."
It seems like that would make it impossible
to do your job without going to meetings,
but apparently, it's not.
It's just difficult.
Southern said,
"We have some briefings, we get some information
that allows us to make the right decisions,
and also allows us to see the role of the
character [so] that we can reflect that in
the toys and the rest of the merchandise.
But there are people on my team that [say],
'I don't want to be there.
I'll work on it, and I'll develop it but I
just don't want to know the context because
I don't want it to be spoiled when I go and
see the film.'
It's a fine balance."
You might think it would be tough for a head
honcho like Southern himself to avoid facing
the full brunt of every spoiler, but apparently,
he finds ways to dodge the big reveals too.
He said,
"There are elements that I don't want to know
about, because ultimately I want to have a
great experience when I go to the cinema.
But I know enough about the architecture of
the film, so that we know what to be focusing
on."
Of course, it's not like Lucasfilm wants to
dole out spoilers left and right; the fewer
of them get out there, the smaller the chance
that they'll make their way to the general
public.
With that in mind, it's interesting to know
that the development process for Star Wars
merchandise can take a little longer than
it does for non-tentpole-related toys, because
the studio will often be intentionally vague
when meeting with the designers.
Take it from Mike Ballog, Senior Director
of Global Marketing for Hasbro, which is handling
the Rise of Skywalker toy line.
He says that design elements of certain toys
will often have to be changed midway through
the development process for that very reason,
a dynamic that has just kind of been factored
into the way they work.
According to him:
"Sometimes, we'll go down the direction that
we think is going to be the best expression,
and then we'll put a model in front of the
[studio] guys and we'll have a conversation,
they'll be like 'well, now he's going to do
this.'
We're like 'oh,' and we'll go back and fix
it.
It's an iterative process."
So the next time you're at the store looking
at Star Wars toys, take a moment to appreciate
all the hard work that's gone into the creations,
and the even harder work that those designers
put in to avoid spoiling themselves for the
new movie.
Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker
hits the big screen on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.